thông thông thông biết đồ nân trăm thông báo Washington sẽ điều thêm năm
nghìn mình dưới tối bà lăn, nhằm cùng có sự hiện vừa quân sự tại đông báo,
đồng thái sĩ xa trường một cạnh chính quyền Mỹ giả só trế lưu của sự tại tró ông,
và nhiều đồng mình nât tôn lo ngại, thái năm Washington thu hẹp hiện diện tại cư vực.
Chuy đó, ở lâu nông gác tưởng thông báo với hoặc giúp khoảng năm
nghìn mình dưới khỏi đất. Tổng thông trăm cho biết quy định tăng quan được đưa ra,
sau các cuộc chứ đổi với tổng thống bà lăn, Khà Rôn, Nà Róc Thì,
bà lăn, hiện là một trong những quốc gia nào tổng có mới chỉ tiêu của phòng cám nhất
liền mình và đón vai tròn chung tâm hộ cạnh hỗ trợ của quay này.
Cùng thư điện hàng thông thân thác giận thông báo của bộ có phòng Nà Truyết,
mắt sức và đăng tính hành của tập trận hạm nhân quy mồ lớn,
từ ngày mi chiến đến ngày 25 năm, với sự tham gia của hơn 6.000 người quân nhân,
hàng chăm bệ phòng tin đưa của một tổng thông hộm chiến đưa.
Ngá đồng thời trình hai đồ đạm nhân Tởi Bên Róc, để diễn thả bệ thông tin đổi s căn đời em.
Bố có phòng bệnh Róc sắc nhận các đơn vị tin đưa và không có nước này,
cũng tham gia hôn đuệnh sự dụng đạm dự đặc biệt với hơn 20 lượng ngay.